[Applause]
hey happy Thursday everybody so you ever
watch something that brings a special
Joy To Your Heart even though you feel
like you shouldn't like it it's gross
and dirty like besides this show
well at 7-Eleven in Stockton California
almost became yet another victim of the
wave of brazen theft sweeping the
country gone are the days when
shoplifting meant putting a Snickers in
your pocket than telling the cashier
you're just glad to see them
ew now shoplifting means lifting the
whole shop at once and humiliating you
in the process roll it
hey let me get a Swisher though can I
get a strip
hey hey can I get this can I get a
Swisher
brother
please
but it's nothing you can do
it's like they're not gonna do nothing
you
[Music]
have insurance
foreign
[Music]
even worse it got me in the mood for a
smoke
laughs
but we all feel how the people in that
store must feel hopeless which is a
weird thing when you're told Law and
Order exists we know it doesn't anymore
so this looks like all the other Smash
and grab videos we're seeing every damn
day just another criminal getting away
with it it's true Haagen-Dazs and
toothpaste get locked up while the
thieves roam free and it's happening
everywhere and why you heard the guy
filming it mention Insurance the idea
being hey you're insured against theft
anyway so who cares right just wait
until the cops come then when the cops
come take your statement and then
nothing ever happens because the local
D.A is too busy giving George Soros a
foot rub
and now the whole neighborhood knows
your store is an easy target criminals
will look at it like it's their parents
fridge as your insurance company finally
says lose my number
at least well that's what usually
happens
but not this time
so let's see the rest of this video and
then tell me how good you feel
afterwards
I know you could do that there's nothing
you could do man
ain't nothing you can do man tell police
come on
don't do that
all right
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
that's called whooping your ass
[Applause]
it's okay to clap
yeah
I mean
I mean talk about cleaning up an aisle
six I haven't seen it beat down like
that since Larry Kudlow tried to try on
tyrus's Belt
That's my kind of convenience store
where thieves get their asses
conveniently beat 24 hours a day and
thank you don't come again now don't get
me wrong I don't like that it gives me
joy to see a man hit with a stick even
if my Google search history says
otherwise
oh look at that it's unknown if the perp
was armed but clearly he acts like it
he's lucky he was hit with a stick and
not a bullet so what are the clerks
supposed to do wait to find out so I got
to be honest I loved every second of
that because I love Justice I love
seeing someone being punished after
threatening their victims and then the
victim exacting the punishment be honest
so did you it's like we all felt it at
once it's clear who the bad guys are
we've had enough of them calling the
shots it's like twist twit Twisted
Sister once said we're not gonna take it
anymore
and they were men wearing makeup
talk about Progressive here's some
responses to that video on Twitter quote
I've watched this 87 times
I love the teamwork yes amazing work
gentlemen Feel Good video of the day it
truly has brightened my day
in other words people were saying the
exact same thing thanks I needed that
so is it really our fault to embrace
violence it's natural however to feel
good when bad people are stopped I mean
the movie industry has made Millions
over the years using that very same plot
and especially when the people in power
let the abuse occur theft used to be
illegal but the politicians who aren't
on the front lines change that and when
creeps know law enforcement won't do it
emboldens them to sweep your livelihood
into a rolling trash can so where's
today's incentive to stop I think you
just saw it the shop owners knew that
too because they eventually let the guy
get up and let him walk out of the store
maybe he'll spread the word that this
place is a no-go Zone like Somalia the
south side of Chicago or Brian
kilmeade's dressing room
the rewards outweigh any punishment it
just makes sense to steal from
hard-working people that's the incentive
the Democrats gave these criminals
remember that the next time you pull the
lever in the polling booth for somebody
with a d after their name you're an
idiot if you're still voting that way
thank you
so is it any wonder that we cheer the
tired hard-working minority shopkeepers
when they literally fight crime you know
it's not just stuff or insurance
premiums these scumbags are stealing the
time these business owners sacrificed
the early mornings the vacations they
give gave up to feed their families and
serve their communities they're the good
guys and the bad guys be glad that stick
didn't end up somewhere else jerk face
so kudos to that 7-Eleven guy for doing
what needed to be done he just showed us
that when it comes to the carrot and the
stick
carrot get the stick
[Applause]
Sunday since whipped cream and hot fudge
host of Fox News Sunday Shannon Bree
people are loving what comes out of his
oven chef and restaurateur Andrew gruel
she can lift a hundred pounds when
robbing a bank in England Fox News
contributor Kat tube
and his pecs tested positive for
massiveness my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Shannon we were on together on the five
earlier and you said during the break
that you love a man with a big stick
I am willing to admit that that was that
brightened my day is what about I mean
well and just listen to the reaction
from the folks here in your audience who
loves you so much
um I mean people do have this steam
valve that is ready to explode I think
when they feel like they don't feel safe
in their neighborhoods they're waiting
20 30 minutes for police to show up not
cops fault I mean if you don't have
enough cops on the beat you don't have
enough people funded they can only do
what they can do but people feel this
frustration and people have to be aware
that when they create a situation in
which people feel like there's no Law
and Order in their Community they're
going to react this way and we don't
want to create a vigilante situation but
if you don't enforce the laws or have
people on bail uh you know or any of
those kinds of things this kind of stuff
is going to happen I wouldn't put this
in the category of vigilantism because
they're not actively going out they're
actually very heated self-defense yes I
will go any self-defense in my book is
good and encouraged Andrew would you say
that that guy as a chef is an expert at
tenderizing meat oh my God oh my God I
mean honestly the uh you know the
Dirtbag cutlets that he made after that
were nothing yeah five star Yelp but
here's the thing things went downhill
for 7-Eleven when they started selling
sushi so I gotta throw that out
and is the cameraman in on this or not I
mean he was like bipolar here yeah he
was full it was for the robber and then
when then he sold him out yeah exactly
what a front runner yeah and and these
guys come in like Jackie Chan and Van
Damme this was the New Age version of
like an 80s kind of you know hero movie
I was excited I jumped out of bed when I
was watching this at 2 30 in the morning
but they didn't cover that at the end
you know when the guy was getting thrown
out he actually asked for a soda he was
like well can I have a soda on the way
out like that's what it's come down to
is this right right like end cut scene
give me a soda give me a soda but he's
gonna go back and he's gonna tell all of
his friends don't go to that place yeah
yeah the soda sucks yeah it's exactly
cat I know you're a very pro-violent
person uh how did you take this video
I don't even like John Wick I know
um okay well I you never know what
someone's going through right so maybe
he needed those cigarettes
for his children yes
he had children that were going through
nicotine withdrawal and they were very
irritable and they kept getting in
trouble at Camp yes that's exactly my
God now I feel terrible about the whole
thing he was a loving father whole
family is like Daddy we need Vapes he's
like I got you know I know what it's
like to have your cigarette stolen yeah
because my brother when I was 18 I was
home for the summer from college he kept
stealing my cigarettes because he was
selling him to his underage friends at a
premium yes and I was like stop stealing
my cigarettes he's like what are you
gonna do tell Mom and Dad he had me yeah
yeah
exactly that's true yeah I mean but also
didn't the guy like say at one point
that he had a gun or something like that
I feel like if someone says you have a
gun you don't wait to find out if they
have a gun no if you have another option
exactly and in this case it was a stick
yeah
I mean that was pretty Tyrus I
I need your analysis on this well a
couple things uh the kid his I loved his
enthusiasm but his rhythm was off on
that
one of the things effective and I think
a lot of parents who still use the
Golden Rule you got to talk during the
ass whippet see if he would have been
comfortable in me like naming every
cigarette as he whooped his ass would
you like some more ultralight Menthol
you have to you have to
you have to get more into yes the
beating you have to enjoy your work yes
you know
and here's this here's the sad part and
I said it to you during the video we've
already accepted this because the man
videoing already had the propaganda
there's nothing you can do let him go he
was high he just wanted his one
cigarette he wanted his Swisher sweet
could you hand me the grape one didn't
care where he got it from but that's the
the sadness of this is that we've
accepted this because
in the old days if I was in there and
the guy probably would have helped him
get him out of the store right now you
got a video away and why are you video
it he's making sure everyone know that
he's not involved other than saying let
him go let him go because there's going
to be consequences not just from
probably the man will end up being
charged with some kind of assault
because they got time to prosecute him
right
or Worse we laugh he will come back but
this time he's not going to come back
with a wall in his pocket yeah he's
going to come back with a gun or he's
going to come back to make an example to
the other store owners in the
neighborhoods you don't do this because
there's no help coming and that's the
part that that we laugh about it they
had a good day today but now that man
with the stick has to be looking over
his shoulder all the time because
there's no help coming because the
people who are making these laws and
these rules they've already decided that
this is the bottom of the barrel let
them like we always say cracks a few
eggs as long as they're fighting in the
dirt they're not in my nice lawn and
that's the message that we're getting
from the Democrats in these cities so
hopefully nothing bad happens but I got
a feeling you don't Whoop a Man's Ass
Like That and he just go away yeah yeah
unless they put him in jail which isn't
obviously going to happen yeah it is
funny watching that guy instead of
helping him out asking for a free
cigarette cigar yeah we're conditioned
to be like hey he just made sure he was
good yeah that's it and that's sad all
right well way to bring me down Tyrus
you know what we're all laughing but
when we see the guy's face rearranged
three months from now we're going to
feel bad about it so that's why I'll
have to go home and watch that video
that's why you got to vote yeah exactly
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else